over what is your move rook 86 is what  we i mean king h1 yeah king h1 yeah look  look h6  yes  knight f5 oh but not if i did no knight  f5 bishop f5 that's yeah that's why i  was posing yeah that no knight takes e4  that's the trick wow wow that's the  trick that's the key  oh my god he's coming in  oh my god that's what level missed he  played the knight g5 too quickly and and  he did not did not calculate all the  things okay we have to take it step by  step knight e4 check king h1 luke h6  seemingly working for black because  knight f5 bishop f5 queen f5 runs into  knight gc winning the queen and winning  the game  but suddenly it turns out that there is  this incredible devilish knight xc for  queen sacrifice luke takes h5 bishop h5  and knife black collects the knight on  e4 with fe4 it runs into luke g1 winning  back the queen winning